This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、保持健康和构建复原力的迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的。收听《2%》。也就是数字2，在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。在《回看》播客节目中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个重要时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《艰难学步》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人背负着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并了解《艰难学步》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，美国广播公司《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑洞大开了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. When we talk about health, I think our first thought is physical health, you know, what food we consume, what exercise we do. how our body feels, what our doctor might say. Then we might think about mental health, psychologically, emotionally, where do we sit, social health, financial health, the list goes on. But rarely do we prioritize our spiritual health, when in fact, spiritual health is really linked
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析20多岁的心理。当我们谈论健康时，我认为我们的第一反应是身体健康，你知道，我们消耗什么食物，做什么锻炼，我们的身体感觉如何，医生可能会说什么。然后我们可能会考虑心理健康，从心理、情绪上来看，我们的状态如何，社交健康，财务健康，这份名单还在继续。但我们很少优先考虑我们的精神健康，事实上，精神健康真的与
to all these other pillars of our well-being. It might not sound as scientific or real as these other dimensions of our health, I think, based on what a lot of society has taught us over the years, but it's really valuable to have something you believe in, especially in your 20s as you're blooming and blossoming into this new person, you have to have something that you have faith in, a sense of meaning, a value system in order to have a fulfilled life. And it's definitely something that I've begun prioritizing more, even though I'm not a religious person anymore. I think that life is just a lot more enjoyable and our sense of purpose is a lot more profound when you can identify a connection
我们福祉的所有其他支柱息息相关。它可能听起来不像我们健康的这些其他维度那样科学或真实，我认为，基于社会多年来教给我们的东西，但拥有你信仰的东西确实很有价值，尤其是在你20多岁时，当你作为这个崭新的人绽放和盛开时，你必须有你信仰的东西、一种意义感、一个价值观体系，才能过上充实的生活。这绝对是我开始更加优先考虑的事情，尽管我不再是一个有宗教信仰的人了。我认为，当你能够确定
between yourself and the world and what you're here for. So I really want to talk about this today and bring the spirituality and the science and the mental health together to kind of understand how an engaged spiritual life and a belief system is so special in our 20s. And of course I had to bring on an incredible guest, Dr. Lisa Miller, she is a professor at Columbia University at clinical psychologist and a scientist, and she focuses on the intersection between spiritual health and our well-being. Lisa, thank you so much for joining us. I'm so happy to be here, and I just really love the way you get right down to what truly matters. These in our 20s, we lay the groundwork for the rest of our lives, and it deserves really being truthful and
自己与世界以及你存在的意义之间的联系时，生活就会变得更有趣，我们的目标感也会深刻得多。所以我今天真的很想谈谈这一点，将灵性、科学和心理健康结合起来，去理解为什么一个投入的精神生活和信仰体系在我们20多岁时如此特别。当然，我不得不请来一位不可思议的嘉宾，丽莎·米勒博士，她是哥伦比亚大学的教授、临床心理学家和科学家，她的研究重点是精神健康与我们福祉之间的交集。丽莎，非常感谢你加入我们。我很高兴来到这里，我真的很喜欢你直奔真正重要的事情的方式。在我们的20多岁时，我们为余生奠定了基础，这非常值得我们做到真实并
getting down to it. So thank you. Oh, absolutely. I really appreciate that. Yeah, not missing around you. I've kind of already given you a little introduction. Do you want to talk more about your path to where you are now, what you do, who you are as a person? Sure. So I'm a clinical scientist. I'm a professor at Columbia University of 25 years. And I have over these years published probably 150 peer review scientific articles on spirituality, who we really are spiritually. and the relationship between our own personal spirituality and our bigger lives, our health, our wellness, our recovery, our strength and character, our thriving. But I'll also share with you, you know, when I talk about how I got here, when I was in my 20s, I was on a spiritual hunt. I mean, I was really on a quest in my 20s.
直奔主题。所以谢谢你。哦，完全不用客气。我真的很感激。是的，没有绕弯子。我已经为你做了一个简单的介绍。你想多谈谈你的成长之路，你是如何走到今天的，你做什么，作为一个真实的人你是谁吗？当然。所以我是个临床科学家。我在哥伦比亚大学担任了25年教授。这些年来，我发表了大约150篇关于灵性、我们在精神上到底是谁，以及我们个人的灵性与我们宏大的人生、我们的健康、我们的福祉、我们的康复、我们的品格力量、我们的繁荣之间的关系的同行评议科学文章。但我也会和你分享，你知道，当我谈到我是如何走到这一步的，当我20多岁时，我在进行一次精神上的探索。我的意思是，我在20多岁时真的在进行一种探寻。
And it was not easy. So if you really want to know how I got here to be a life. long scientist and someone who's devoted themselves to this work, it starts in my 20s. You know, I was 19 years old, 20 years old, starting out, and I really started to wonder, you know, what the purpose of life really was. And this was no joke. I'd always been kind of a thoughtful person, but I really started to wonder. It sort of was just tug from within. And that tug became about a hundred times more fierce when there was a bump in my life. When people have different bumps, it doesn't matter. It turns out what the bump might be.
这并不容易。所以如果你真的想知道我是如何走到这一步，成为一个终身科学家并致力于这项工作的人，这一切都始于我的20多岁。你知道，我当时19岁，20岁，刚刚开始，我真的开始想知道，你知道，人生的真正目的到底是什么。这不是开玩笑。我一直是一个善于思考的人，但我真的开始想知道。这就像是内心深处的一种拉扯。当我的生活遇到坎坷时，这种拉扯变得比原来强烈了一百倍。当人们遇到不同的坎坷时，这并不重要。事实证明，坎坷本身可能是什么并不重要。
But for me, my true love, the first time I'd ever, ever been in love, completely broke my heart. I mean, so here was this guy. I'd fallen in love for the first time. And I thought he was perfect. You know, he was in my eyes more handsome than a Greek sculpture. He was so interesting. He was you know, I was mesmerized. And he said, you know what? I really think I'm falling in love with you. And I said, you love me. He's like, yeah, I love you. And that was after three months. And I found the person I'm going to marry. And then after he broke up with me. Boom, five months. And I was shocked. It didn't make sense. Like I said, but you, you love me. He's like, no, I did. And I said, but now you don't love me. And he's like, no. I did. And I said, but now you don't love me. And he's like, no. No, not now. I'm like, well, you did then, but you don't now. How can that be? He's like, well, there was a change. And I thought, well, if you can change, you know, does love really matter? Is love real? I mean, if you can love me, truly love me and then truly not love me is love real. And ever more, like, I started to think, well, wait a minute. What is our human condition that we can so-called fall out of love? Is there any permanence or stability to us? You know, what can you really bank on. Can you trust people in life? And this sent me on a huge spiral about what is the nature of life, what is real, are humans real, is love real? And these were not questions that were somehow a symptom of pathology. These were genuine, real questions. So what do you think I did? I went to a therapist.
但对我来说，我的真爱，我这辈子第一次经历过的爱，彻底心碎了。我的意思是，所以这就是这个家伙。我第一次坠入爱河。我认为他是完美的。你知道，在我眼里，他比希腊雕塑还要帅。他太有趣了。他，你知道，我被迷住了。他说，你知道吗？我真的觉得我爱上你了。我说，你爱我？他说，是的，我爱。那是三个月后。我找到了我要结婚的人。然后在他和我分手之后。轰，五个月。我很震惊。这说不通。就像我说的那样，但是你，你爱我。他说，不，我爱过。我说，但你现在不爱我了。他说，不。我爱过。我说，但你现在不爱我了。他说，不。不，现在不是。我说，好吧，你那时候爱，但你现在不爱。怎么会这样？他说，嗯，发生了变化。我想，好吧，如果你能改变，你知道，爱真的很重要吗？爱是真实的吗？我的意思是，如果你能爱我，真正地爱我，然后又真正地不爱我，爱是真实的吗？更重要的是，我开始想，好吧，等一下。我们的身心状况是什么，让我们能够所谓地不再相爱？我们有任何持久性或稳定性吗？你知道，你真正能信赖的是什么？你能在生活中信任别人吗？这让我陷入了一场巨大的漩涡，关于生命的本质是什么，什么是真实的，人类是真实的吗，爱是真实的吗？这些问题绝不是某种病理症状。这些是真诚的、真实的问题。所以你觉得我做了什么？我去看了一位治疗师。
And I went first therapist and I said, listen, you know, I have really been on a downward spiral since John broke up with me. I don't know if love's real. I don't know if we can really count on each other. Do we just change overnight? Are we so stable or real? And I really wonder, you know, I used to really believe in God or a higher power, whatever one's word might be, the universe. And now I don't know how much I can really count even on that. Is God real? It's the universe, in the sense of being loving and there for us personally real. And the therapist looked at my story and said, so you don't know if God's really there for you. And I said, yeah, I don't know if God's real. And she said, well, was your father there for you when you were little? And I'm like,
我去找了第一位治疗师，我说，听着，你知道，自从约翰和我分手以来，我真的陷入了螺旋式下降。我不知道爱是不是真的。我不知道我们是否真的可以依靠彼此。我们只是在一夜之间改变吗？我们是如此稳定或真实吗？我真的很想知道，你知道，我以前真的很相信上帝或某种更高力量，无论人们怎么称呼它，宇宙。现在我不知道我甚至能在多大程度上真正依靠那个。上帝是真的吗？宇宙在充满爱、为我们个人存在的意义上是真的吗？治疗师看着我的故事说，所以你不知道上帝是否真的为你存在？我说，是的，不知道上帝是不是真的。她说，好吧，当你小的时候，你父亲为你存在吗？我说，
wait a minute. No, I don't mean that my father isn't there for me. I mean, I don't know God is there for me. And she can only tell that one story that were nothing more than the paths of our childhood. So, you know, I thought this isn't for me. And I went, fired her, which she should do. She always fire a therapist if it's not right. And I went to a new therapist. And I told the same story and she said, okay, so you don't know if God's there for you. Do you think you have low self-esteem? Do you think that you have sort of negative self-talk? And I said, no, I'm fine with myself. I don't know if God's real. Right. And this turned out to be what I have now come decades later to know is the most important work that we do, which is figure out.
等一下。不，我不是那个意思，我不是说我父亲不在我身边。我的意思是，我不知道上帝是否为我存在。她只能讲那个故事，认为我们不过是童年轨迹的产物。所以，你知道，我觉得这不适合我。然后我去了，解雇了她，这是你应该做的。如果不合适，就应该解雇治疗师。然后我换了一个新治疗师。我讲了同一个故事，她说，好吧，所以你不知道上帝是否为你存在？你觉得自己有自卑感吗？你觉得你有一些消极的自我对话吗？我说，没有，我对自我感觉很好。我只是不知道上帝是不是真的。对。事实证明，几十年后，我才意识到这是我们做的最重要的工作，那就是弄清楚。
the spiritual reality and who we are in the spiritual reality. Mental health didn't know that. Psychologists, therapists didn't know that. College counselors didn't know that. They thought that this big quest was actually just a symptom of depression. But now we know, you know, hundreds of peer-review scientific articles later, that this is not just, you know, a sidebar of depression. This is literally how we are built. We are hardwired, our brain, our genes, to grow up. into our 20s and need to quest and we're even better at it in our 20s. I'm listening to that story and just being like, wow, can completely relate, have seen this happen so many times, have seen it happen in myself. And the listeners of the show
精神现实以及我们在精神现实中的身份。心理健康并不知道这一点。心理学家、治疗师并不知道这一点。大学辅导员并不知道这一点。他们认为这种巨大的探寻其实只是抑郁症的一种症状。但现在我们知道了，你知道，几百篇同行评议的科学文章之后，这不仅仅是抑郁症的副产品。这简直就是我们的构建方式。我们的大脑和基因是天生为了成长而硬编码的，
will know a couple months ago, I went through an incredibly similar experience where I was like, okay, what's the meaning of life? What happens after we die? How do you go on knowing that it's finite, yada, yada, yada, an existential crisis. And so I went to a therapist and she asked me if I had watched any scary movies as a phrase. So it's so funny, right? And then they were like, oh, we'll just up your antidepressants as a way to combat this. And I think it was kind of like the first line of defense. I accepted it. And then now I've gotten to a place much like you have where it's like, actually, this is an upending question. If I don't answer it now, I'll have to answer it eventually.
进入20多岁时，我们需要进行探索，而且我们在20多岁时做得更好。我听着那个故事，心里就在想，哇，完全能感同身受，已经看到这种情况发生过好多次，也曾在自己身上看到过这种情况。这个节目的听众
I'll have to answer it in three years time, in my 30s, in my 40s. And my mom said something to me. She was like, this is something that you're going to continue to struggle with until you have a belief system that you can rely on, not one that any institution or a therapist has told you. And you gave chills because you are so deep and so wise. And here I am with tears in my eyes because you knew the truth, that this was a very real, very personal.
会知道几个月前，我经历了一次极其相似的经历，当时我在想，好吧，生命的意义是什么？我们死后会发生什么？你怎么能带着对有限性的认知继续生活，等等，等等，存在主义危机。所以我去找了一位治疗师，作为开场白，她问我有没有看过什么恐怖电影。所以这太搞笑了，对吧？然后他们说，哦，我们会帮你增加抗抑郁药的剂量来对抗这个。我想这就像是第一道防线。我接受了。然后现在我到了一个和你很像的阶段，就像是，实际上，这是一个颠覆性的问题。如果我现在不回答它，我最终还是得回答它。
profound. It's a sacred quest. And I'm deep moved that you knew exactly what it was. You didn't let a so-called expert tell you that your experience was somehow anything other than profound. Thank you. And it's hard, you know, because when you have such a scientific and a psychological perspective, that is where you look first. And I think people might be listening to this being like, where does God come in here? You know, we're talking about God. We're talking about Allah. maybe these big figures. One of the biggest questions and I think conundrums people have when they think about spirituality is, does that mean I have to be religious? So what in your mind is the difference between spirituality and religion? Can you have like a non-denominational quest?
我不得不在三年后回答它，在我30多岁、40多岁的时候。我妈妈对我说过一些话。她说，这是你将一直纠结的事情，直到你拥有一个你可以信赖的信仰体系，而不是任何机构或治疗师告诉你的体系。你让我起鸡皮疙瘩，因为你太深刻、太睿智了。我眼里含着泪水，因为你知道真相，这是一个非常真实、非常个人化、
What you just shared was a deeply profound spiritual quest that is actually hardwired in every single one of us. So what your journey reveals needing to answer the profound questions, an existential crisis, as you put it, the very nature of our existence. This is in our birthright. And we now have a very good science of 20 years that says just as we're physical, emotional, cognitive beings, we are all spiritual beings. And we even have found the circuits in the brain using MRI studies that are the spiritual circuit. And it turns out that every single person on earth, every 7.2 billion people on earth, all have the same spiritual circuits. So spirituality is inborn. It's innate. And we know this ever more through the lens of a twin study. We look at twins raised together and twins raised apart. And we can
深远的经历。这是一次神圣的探寻。我深受感动，因为你确切地知道那是什么。你没有让所谓的专家告诉你，你的经历除了深刻之外还有别的什么。谢谢。这很难，你知道，因为当你拥有这样一种科学和心理学的视角时，那就是你首先看的地方。我想人们听到这里可能会觉得，上帝是从哪里切入的？你知道，我们在谈论上帝。我们在谈论真主。也许是这些伟大的神明。人们在思考灵性时，最大的问题和谜团之一是：这是否意味着我必须要有宗教信仰？那么在你的脑海中，灵性和宗教的区别是什么？你可以进行一种非宗派的探寻吗？
determine whether any human capacity is inborn or environmentally formed. And spirituality is innate. religion, whether we are Catholic, Hindu, Muslim, Jewish, Jane, whatever our tradition may be, right? Religion is not inborn. Religion is environmentally transmitted. So the texts and the ceremonies and the teachings are a gift of the environment. But spirituality is a deep, inborn human capacity. And because it's inborn, it has natural phases of development, including the most precious phase, which is in our 20s, we become independent spiritual beings on our own terms, on our own inner heart. We need to figure out what's true and not true, the inner compass of spiritual reality. And what does that feel like when you kind of come to that point,
你刚才分享的是一次极其深邃的精神探寻，它实际上已经硬编码在我们每个人身上。所以你的旅程揭示了你需要回答深刻的问题，即存在主义危机，正如你所说，我们存在的本质。这是我们的与生俱来的权利。我们现在有了20年来非常出色的科学研究，它表明，正如我们是身体、情感、认知的生命一样，我们全都是精神的生命。我们甚至通过磁共振成像研究在脑海中找到了作为精神回路的电路。事实证明，地球上的每一个人，地球上所有的72亿人，都有相同的精神回路。所以灵性是天生的。它是与生俱来的。我们通过双胞胎研究的镜头更加了解这一点。我们观察一起长大的双胞胎和分开长大的双胞胎。我们可以
whatever religion or non-religion or agnostic atheist environment you've been raised in, does it always look like a spiritual crisis or does it look like an awakening? Well, your question is very beautiful because most people at some point have some type of struggle or crisis, the testing of everything they've been taught or told against the deep knowing of their own inner heart. You know, what is the resonance? And so whether it is at 22 or 29, you know, somewhere in the 20s, there is, wait a minute, everything you ever told me, you know, Pastor, Priest, Amon, Rabbi, Grandma, Grandpa,
确定任何人类能力是天生的还是环境形成的。灵性是天生的。宗教，无论我们是天主教徒、印度教徒、穆斯林、犹太人、耆那教徒，无论我们的传统是什么，对吧？宗教不是天生的。宗教是通过环境传递的。所以文本、仪式和教义是环境的馈赠。但灵性是一种深刻的、与生俱来的内在人类能力。正因为它是天生的，它有自然的自然发展阶段，包括最珍贵的阶段，那就是在我们20多岁时，我们按照自己的条件、按照自己内心的心声，成为了独立的精神存在。我们需要弄清楚什么是真理，什么是虚假，即精神现实的内在罗盘。当你达到那个点时，那种感觉是怎样的，
Mom, Dad, I need to know it as true against my own inner compass. That's called spiritual emergence. And it is a mark of entering into adulthood. It is an incredibly, is the cornerstone of adulthood. So that is absolutely essential to emerging as our own person in the world. But you're also raising another,
无论你是在什么样的宗教、非宗教或不可知论无神论环境中长大的，它总是看起来像是一场精神危机，还是看起来像是一场觉醒？你的问题非常优美，因为大多数人在某个时刻都会经历某种挣扎或危机，用他们内心的深知来检验他们被教导或被告知的一切。你知道，什么是共鸣？所以无论是在22岁还是29岁，你知道，在20多岁的某个时候，会有一种想法，等一下，你曾对我说过的一切，你知道，牧师、神父、伊玛目、拉比、奶奶、爷爷、
coolly beautiful and important point, which is sometimes, you know, in addition to that, someone who's been on a quest, someone who's struggled or someone who will someday struggle, also may have moments of extraordinary awakening. You know, suddenly you might have a dream, or you could have a mystical experience or a synchronicity when two events are way too unprobabilistic to have just happened by chance. They go together, deeply. And that type of spiritual experience in the world is a gift. That is a way of, you know, the universe who I call God, your higher power, the force of life saying, you are never alone. You are guided, you are loved, and you are held. And it's so beautiful the way that you talk about it is like,
这种清醒的美丽和重要的观点是，有时候，除了这些，一个一直在探索的人，一个经历过挣扎的人，或者一个终将经历挣扎的人，也可能会有非凡觉醒的时刻。你知道，突然之间你可能会做一个梦，或者你可能会经历一次神秘体验，又或者当两个事件太不可能纯粹是巧合发生时，会出现一种同步性。它们深度地契合在一起。世上这种精神体验是一份礼物。这是一种方式，你知道的，我称之为上帝、你的更高力量、生命之力的宇宙在对你说，你从不孤单。你被引导着，你被爱着，你被拥抱着。你谈论它的方式真是太美妙了，就像是，
it doesn't need to be in a box. There is no one right answer for what is real. It's what calls you to see a higher purpose and a higher meaning. Whatever that comes to you as. And it's a highly individual experience, which I think is what sometimes can frustrate people. It's like, well, I just want to know the answer. I just want to know what's real and what is the one truth. And I think the thing about spirituality is it's not about having the one answer. It's about having the structure and the belief system, the same way you believe in so many other things. You believe that you are alive. if you believe that you have a purpose, you believe that you are capable of being loved. It's like you believe that there is something more.
它不需要被局限在一个框框里。对于什么是真实的，没有哪个唯一的正确答案。它是指引你去看到更高目的和更高意义的事物。无论它以何种形式来到你身边。这是一个高度个人化的体验，我认为这有时会让人感到沮丧。就像是，好吧，我只是想知道答案。我只想知道什么是真的，什么是唯一的真理。我认为关于灵性的事情在于，它不是关于拥有唯一的答案。而是关于拥有结构和信仰系统，就像你信仰许多其他事物一样。你相信自己还活着。如果你相信自己有存在的目标，你相信自己有能力被爱。就像你相信还有更多一样。
What have you seen in your studies when people aren't able to find that belief? Or perhaps they continue to suppress their need for something more? You put it so beautifully because spirituality is not a theory, right? it is our ability to perceive into the deeper nature of life. Spirituality is a seat of awareness. And so what you're describing is really, it's almost like a sacred operating manual. How do I look into the world?
在你的研究中，当人们无法找到那种信仰时，你看到了什么？或者也许他们继续压抑自己对更多事物的需求？你表达得太美妙了，因为灵性不是一种理论，对吧？它是我们感知生命更深层本质的能力。灵性是觉察的基石。所以你所描述的实际上，几乎就像一本神圣的操作手册。我如何看待这个世界？
What is my stance? And that is a deeply personal journey to arrive into our own dialogue with the universe. And I can share with you that when we do that work, we are profoundly protected against addiction, against depression, against some forms even of harm or suicide. There's nothing more protective against this real sort of global epidemic of the diseases of despair in 20-year-olds. Nothing is more profoundly protective as our deep spiritual seat of awareness. So again, it may or may not be through one's religion that one finds that, that deep, personal sense of quest to have our bearings in life. What is life showing me now? What is my
我的立场是什么？这是一个极其个人的旅程，通往我们自己与宇宙的对话。我可以与你们分享的是，当我们做这项工作时，我们能够深刻地抵御成瘾、抑郁，甚至某些形式的伤害或自杀。没有什么比这更能抵御20多岁年轻人中普遍存在的绝望疾病流行了。没有什么比我们深层的灵性觉察基石更能提供深厚的保护了。所以同样地，一个人可能会也可能不会通过某种宗教来找到这种对生活的深刻个人探索感。生活现在在向我展示什么？我的
higher power asking or revealing to me now? What does that synchronicity mean? Was that a sacred dream? Was that a mystical experience? And knowing our spiritual experience to be true, that is real. Know it's true. Take it as extremely important. Reflect on it and then act on it. So there's no way of knowing that is as strong and sure and helps us along as much as our spiritual way of knowing. Actually, could we do a brief 90-second practice where people have a chance to engage their spiritual awareness? Absolutely. We love anything practical on this show, please. Beautiful.
更高力量现在在要求我什么或向我揭示什么？那个同步性意味着什么？那是一个神圣的梦吗？那是一次神秘体验吗？并且知道我们的灵性体验是真实的，那就是真实的。知道它是真实的。把它当作极其重要的事情。反思它然后付诸行动。因此，没有什么比我们的灵性认知方式更强大、更确定、更能帮助我们了。实际上，我们可以做一个简短的90秒练习，让大家有机会投入到他们的灵性觉察中吗？当然可以。我们喜欢这个节目中的任何实用练习，请开始吧。太棒了。
Okay, beautiful. So I'm going to invite you to just, it's a 90-second practice, clear out your inner space, close your eyes, an invitation if you wish, to close your eyes. and take five big, beautiful breaths to open up your inner chamber. And in your inner chamber, I invite you to set before you a table. This is your table. Into your table, you may invite anyone living or deceased who truly has your best interest in mind. Anyone living or deceased who truly has your best interest in mind.
好的，太棒了。所以我要邀请大家，这是一个90秒的练习，清空你的内心空间，闭上眼睛，如果你愿意的话，可以闭上眼睛。做五个深沉、美好的呼吸来打开你的内心密室。在你的内心密室里，我邀请你在面前放置一张桌子。这是你的桌子。你可以邀请任何在世或已故、真正为你最大利益着想的人来到你的桌子前。任何在世或已故、真正为你最大利益着想的人。
And with them all sitting there, ask them if, they love you. And now you may invite your higher self, the part of you that is so much more than anything you might have done or not done, anything that you might have or not have, your true, eternal higher self. And ask you if you love you. And now finally, you may invite your higher power, however you know, whatever word is yours, your higher. And you are your higher. power and ask if they love you. And now with all of those people sitting there right now, what do they need to tell you now? What do you need to know? What do they need to share right now? Wow. I feel very tingling. It's quite a beautiful exercise. Have you seen people like come out of
随着他们全部坐在那里，问问他们是否，他们爱你。现在你可以邀请你的更高自我，也就是超越了你可能做过或没做过、拥有或没拥有任何事物的那个部分的你，你真正的、永恒的更高自我。问问你自己是否爱你。现在最后，你可以邀请你的更高力量，无论你如何认知，无论哪个词属于你，你的更高。你是你的更高。力量并询问他们是否爱你。现在，随着所有这些人此刻坐在那里，他们现在需要告诉你什么？你需要知道什么？他们现在需要分享什么？哇。我感到非常刺痛。这是一个非常美丽的练习。你见过人们从
that and just be like, I have a complete new truth. Like I completely have rethought. how I think about myself. I've seen people deeply moved and awakened because they realize, yes, you are spiritual. This is you. You are spiritual. And no one can ever take this away from you. Wow. It was so interesting when you were thinking about the table. I also feel like I was thinking about this big family dinner table. And it wasn't just people, but it was like pets as well. I don't know why. I was like, oh, yeah, and there's my childhood dog and there's my current dog. and they're, you know, sitting at this table. I don't know why. It's just like, oh, of course, people I want to see. So I feel about my dog. I love my dog and I feel that we're all souls,
那个状态中走出来，然后说，我拥有了一个全新的真理。就像我完全重新思考了我如何看待自己。我看到人们被深深打动并觉醒，因为他们意识到，是的，你是灵性的。这就是你。你是灵性的。没有人能把这个从你身上夺走。哇。当你想到这张桌子时，这太有趣了。我也觉得我在想这张全家福的大餐桌。不仅有人，还有宠物，不知道为什么。我想，哦，是的，那是我童年时的狗，这是我现在的狗。他们，你知道的，坐在桌子旁。我不知道为什么。这就像是，哦，当然，我想见的人。所以我对我的狗也有这种感觉。我爱我的狗，我觉得我们都是灵魂，
that our dogs are souls and we're here together. I know. It's interesting how, like, that thought exercise gives you a new perspective on what to you, like, constitutes a soul and what to you constitutes love and how that's reflected. It's a beautiful exercise. So at my table, it's not always the same people every time, right? And what's nice about this practice is that we can bring to counsel. This is your counsel, right? What is on our heart at any given moment. So if someone is really, you know, I felt very unkind to me or is not, or has betrayed
我们的狗也是灵魂，我们在这里相聚。我知道。有趣的是，那种思维练习如何给你带来新的视角，关于对你而言什么构成了灵魂，什么构成了爱，以及这如何得到反映。这是一个美丽的练习。所以在我桌子旁的人并不是每次都一样，对吧？这个练习的好处在于我们可以将其带入委员会。这就是你的委员会，对吧？我们在任何给定时刻内心的想法。因此，如果有人真的，你知道的，我觉得对我非常不友善，或者不是，或者背叛了
me or working against me, I can bring that experience and even that person in my mind to counsel. So for example, if you're, even if you've got some. some huge decision, perhaps after a breakup or you're at a crossroads in terms of your career or some tragedy has happened. It is almost like you've got this perfect panel of everyone who represents love and joy and care and empathy to you who you can ask in your own mind without actually needing them there. Is that kind of the premise as well? Yes, beautifully put. Exactly. They are, this panel is always there for you. Always. And who shows up may change,
我，或者与我作对，我可以在心中把那段经历甚至那个人带到委员会前。因此，举个例子，如果你正在，甚至如果你有一些。重大的决定，也许在分手之后，或者你正处于职业生涯的十字路口，或者发生了某种悲剧。这几乎就像你拥有了一个完美的专家组，里面全是你心目中代表爱、喜悦、关怀和同理心的人，你可以在自己的心中向他们询问，而不需要他们实际在场。这也是这种前提吗？是的，表达得很美妙。完全正确。他们，这个专家组永远为你都在。永远。出现的人可能会改变，
but you can ask them what is on your heart. And that's like one exercise I think that gets us in touch with a sense of spirituality, even if you don't think you have it, even if, you know, you have strange feelings about it that you've been conditioned to think. How else do we really begin to build out a spiritual core in a similar way. I feel like that's a great exercise for being like, okay, I've recognized that at my core, I do have a deep belief and a deep intrinsic sense of being present, being here, being loved. How do we make sure that carries with us in other parts of our life and begin to build like those pillars of what do I believe in? So that's a very beautiful question because we can have a moment, a breakthrough. It can be a
但你可以向他们询问你内心的想法。我认为这是一个能让我们接触到灵性感悟的练习，即使你认为自己没有，即使你，你知道的，对它有奇怪的感觉，那是你过去被灌输形成的观念。我们如何真正开始以类似的方式建立一个精神核心？我觉得这是一个很好的练习，可以让人觉得，好吧，我认识到在我的核心，我确实拥有深刻的信仰和深层的内在感知，即当下的存在、此地的存在、被爱。我们如何确保这伴随着我们生活中的其他部分，并开始建立那些信仰支柱：我信仰什么？所以这是一个非常美丽的问题，因为我们可以拥有一个时刻，一个突破。它可以通过
through a practice like we just shared here, the hosting council, or it could come to us spontaneously. We could be on a hike and see the sun on the lake and it's just so breathtakingly beautiful that we feel a sense of oneness. We feel a presence of God or the higher power, the universe. We can have moments of awakening. But the question is how to really integrate spirituality into our lives, how to really build what you were talking about earlier, which is a sacred operating manual, a way of being in the world, an understanding of how to engage day in and day out with the sacred presence for the universe. And that journey is, again, it doesn't happen in two days. It's really developed in our 20s if we give it the care and the love and the attention and the time. But we're
像我们刚才在这里分享的练习，即接待委员会，或者它可能自发地降临。我们可能在远足时看到湖面上的阳光，它是如此 breathtaking 地美丽，以至于我们感受到了一种合一感。我们感受到了上帝或更高力量、宇宙的存在。我们可以拥有觉醒的时刻。但问题是如何真正将灵性融入我们的生活，如何真正建立你刚才谈到的内容，也就是一本神圣的操作手册，一种在世间生存的方式，一种理解如何日复一日与宇宙的神圣存在进行互动的方式。而这段旅程，同样地，它不是在两天内发生的。如果我们给予它关怀、爱、关注和时间，它确实是在我们20多岁时发展起来的。但我们
never, ever as good at it as we are in our 20s. So you have a gift right now. You have a gift right now. You are better in your 20s than in your 40s, 50s or 60s at being basically spiritual seekers, knowing in the heart what is true, knowing what's fake and hypocrisy, hungering for what is genuine and transcendent and not wanting something that is unworthy or shallow. You are built to be exquisite spiritual seekers. So there's no time like our 20s where we are, as good as building this deep stance in living, which means, you know, we can't control things in life and the world's getting more complex. We can't control the environment. We can't control the big office, all this. But we certainly can control a deep stance of spiritual quest. What is life
从来没有，也永远不会像在我们20多岁时那样擅长它。所以你现在就有一份礼物。你现在就有一份礼物。在成为基本上是灵性求索者、在内心中知道什么是真、知道什么是虚伪和虚伪、渴望真实和超越而非不值得或浅薄事物方面，你20多岁时的表现要比40多岁、50多岁或60多岁时更好。你们生来就是精致的灵性求索者。所以没有哪个时期比我们20多岁时更适合建立这种深层的生存立场，这意味着，你知道的，我们无法控制生活中的事情，世界变得越来越复杂。我们无法控制环境。我们无法控制宏大的办公室，所有这些。但我们绝对可以控制一种深层的灵性求索立场。生活现在在
showing me now? What is life revealing to me now? Not why is this happening to me, but why is this happening for me? Start with a premise that your life is an incredible spiritual adventure and everything is a portal to incredible expansion and growth so nothing is a bummer everything is going to make you more not less even if it's hurt and it's not and it's not bad people there's plenty of bad people but it's not it doesn't matter if it we wanted it or not wanted it it's all part of the spiritual path and it'll all make us deeper and more profound. So nothing in your life is wasted. Nothing in your life is off the spiritual path. Everything is going in the end to make you more, not less. That's the first point. The second thing is people are
向我展示什么？生活现在在向我揭示什么？不是为什么这会发生在我身上，而是为什么这对我发生？从你的生活是一场不可思议的灵性冒险这个前提开始，一切都是通往不可思议的扩展和成长的入口，所以没有什么是倒霉的，一切都会让你变得更多，而不是更少，即使它伴随着伤害，并且它不是，它不是坏人，有很多坏人，但它不是，不管我们想要还是不想要它，这都是灵性道路的一部分，这一切最终都会让我们更深刻、更有深度。所以你生活中的任何事情都不会被浪费。你生活中的任何事情都不会偏离灵性道路。最终一切都会让你变得更多，而不是更少。这是第一点。第二点是人们会
like, okay, well, how do I do this? And there's a lot of people going out right now and they go in retreats. Maybe they'll try ayahuasca. They'll have a breakthrough. Okay. And the question is, well, okay, there's a breakthrough, but what am I going to do next? And we don't want to turn around and go touch the stone two weeks later. You can't do ayahuasca every two weeks, right? You can't live a life that way. So how do you integrate spiritual breakthrough, whether it's through mystical experience or ayahuasca or prayer, or you've meditated or you've seen nature? And there's four pieces. There's four ingredients. May I get into it? Absolutely. Yes, please. Yes, please. So the way I think of it is four p's as a way to remember it. A practice of transcendence.
觉得，好吧，那我该怎么做呢？现在有很多人出去参加隐修。也许他们会尝试死藤水。他们会有一个突破。好的。问题是，好吧，有了突破，那我接下来该做什么呢？我们不想转过身去两周后又去摸那块石头。你不能每两周就搞一次死藤水，对吧？你不能那样生活。那么你如何整合精神突破，无论是通过神秘体验、死藤水、祈祷、冥想还是观察大自然呢？有四个部分。有四个要素。我可以讲讲吗？当然可以。好的，请讲。好的，请讲。所以我思考它的方式是用四个P作为记忆方法。超越的实践。
You know, whether it's some form of breathwork or prayer or meditation or being in nature, but some way of getting back to that deep sense that you saw when you saw light upon the ocean, when you had a mystical dream, when you held your counsel or practice. Number two is your people. So you've created here, this beautiful international community. You've created people, right, a place to go to and share spiritual life so that we're not at it alone. and the freedom and the authority to use our spiritual voice when we connect with one another. And I want to know you in the deepest way.
你知道，无论是某种呼吸法、祈祷、冥想，还是身处大自然，但总归是某种能让你重新找回那种深层感知的方法——就像你看到阳光洒在海洋上时感受到的，当你做了一个神秘的梦时，当你举行委员会练习时。第二点是你的伙伴。所以你们在这里创造了一个美丽的国际社群。你们创造了伙伴，对吧？一个可以前往并分享精神生活的地方，这样我们就不是孤军奋战。并且拥有在彼此连接时使用我们灵性声音的自由和权威。我想以最深的方式了解你。
And I'm interested in your spiritual voice to our practice, our people. The third is the path. And that's where you started today, which is a way of understanding, you know, the biggest existential questions in life. How do I walk this earth? And I don't mean, you know, am I going to become a teacher or a banker or an entertainer? I mean, as a soul on earth, how do I walk this earth? And then finally, this is something you said in our first two minutes together, our purpose, my ultimate purpose on earth.
我对你对我们的实践、我们的伙伴所表达的灵性声音很感兴趣。第三个是道路。这就是你今天开始的地方，也就是一种理解方式，你知道的，生命中最大的存在主义问题。我如何在这世上行走？我不是指，你知道的，我要成为一名老师、银行家还是艺人？我的意思是，作为一个尘世的灵魂，我如何在这世上行走？最后，这是你在我们在一起的前两分钟里说过的话，我们的目的，我在世上的终极目的。
So you're practice your people, your past, and your purpose. That's a fully integrated spiritual life. Wow. And even like applying that on my own, on what I've experienced quite recently, this is quite a profound conversation because I feel like it came at a perfect time. I think about, you know, my practice in many ways is like making this podcast and it's thinking quite deeply about things which can eventually be confronting. And that is most likely what happened in my situation where it was like, huh, I can no longer find like a link between all of my experiences and all these terrible things are happening in the world and people are suffering and people are, you know, sparing and there's just all these things. And I've been really sitting in that like, knowledge and thinking about it a lot. And I think that the community that came around me in that time was incredibly important. Like I speak about it in the episode where I spoke about this crisis.
所以是你的实践、你的伙伴、你的道路和你的目的。这是一个完全整合的精神生活。哇。甚至就像把它应用在我自己身上，应用在我最近经历的事情上，这是一场非常深刻的对话，因为我觉得它来得正是时候。我想到了，你知道的，我的实践在许多方面就像是制作这个播客，它深入思考那些最终可能会带来对抗性的事情。这极有可能是我的情况所发生的事情，当时就像是，哼，我再也无法在我的所有经历和世界上发生的所有这些可怕的事情之间找到联系，人们在受苦，人们在，你知道的，绝望，所有这些事情都在发生。我一直在深入思考这种知识并思考了很多。我认为在那段时间围绕着我的社群非常重要。就像我在讲述这场危机的单集里谈到的一样。
It was family. It was literally the council. It was it was the panel. It was family. It was my partner. It was my closest friends. And it really did show me who my closest friends were as well, which was quite interesting. And I kind of came to this conclusion. And I remember like being in my house and almost like pacing. Like I would move from the bedroom to the lounge room to the kitchen to the lounge room, like it was a very circular thing. And one day I was like, I just think that maybe not the purpose. But what was the third?
那是家人。字面意思就是委员会。它是。它是专家组。那是家人。那是我的伴侣。那是我最亲密的朋友。它确实也向我展示了谁是我最亲密的朋友，这非常有趣。我几乎得出了这个结论。我记得当时在我的家里，几乎在踱步。我会从卧室走到客厅，再到厨房，再到客厅，这是一个非常循环的过程。有一天我想，我只是觉得也许不是目的。但第三个是什么？
What was the third one? I've just already forgotten it. The path, yeah. And I think mine was like, the path is just to be love, to just be love. Like that is all you need to be. And that's going to come in many forms. but the way that you walk through life is in any single encounter with any single person being environment, your job is to just be this brilliant, bright orb that people can look to and say,
第三个是什么？我刚刚已经忘了。道路，对。我想我的意思是，道路就是去爱，仅仅去爱。这就是你需要成为的一切。这会以多种形式出现。但你穿行于生活的方式，是在与任何一个人、任何环境的每一次相遇中，你的任务就是成为那个明亮的光球，人们可以看着它并说，
okay, well, this is love and this is kindness and this is warmth. And the purpose of that, obviously right now, this feels like my purpose. The podcast is the way that I perform and I approach the path. But maybe in the future it's going to be something else. And I think that also allowed me to not tie my spirituality and my belief in life to a specific career to what I was doing right now, even to like a specific relationship. That's why I really like that model that you've just introduced to us, right? It's like, no matter what stage in life you're at, you can find a way to bring meaning to what you're doing.
好的，这就是爱，这就是善良，这就是温暖。而这的目的，显然现在，这感觉像是我的目的。播客是我践行和接近道路的方式。但也许在未来它会变成别的东西。我想这也让我不再把我的灵性和对生活的信仰绑死在某个特定的职业上，绑死在我现在所做的事情上，甚至绑死在某个特定的关系上。这就是为什么我真的很喜欢你刚刚向我们介绍的那个模型，对吧？就像是，无论你处于人生的哪个阶段，你都能找到一种方法为你所做的事情赋予意义。
And maybe that is by keeping an ongoing list of what you're being taught in the moment, keeping an ongoing list of things that have felt pivotal to you, creating like a narrative and a story throughout your life. And then reflecting on community, reflecting on what your deep value is, is it love, is it creativity, is it generosity? I think that is a really practical way to think about it. If you can envision a world where everyone does what you just said, let's just say all of Gen Z does what you just said, which is what you just said, which is what. walk a path of abundant love, then you will have turned the world. You'll have done it, Gen C. I know. And it's just, you know, it's wild to me that I guess obviously there are so many different challenges and faults in the road and real pivotal crises that are happening to us
也许这可以通过列一张持续更新的清单来实现：此时此刻你正在被传授什么，列一张对你感觉至关重要的事物清单，在你的整个生活中创造一种叙事和故事。然后反思社群，反思你的核心价值是什么，是爱，是创造力，还是慷慨？我认为这真的是一种非常实用的思考方式。如果你能设想这样一个世界：每个人都做你刚刚所说的事情，比方说，Z世代的所有人都做你刚刚所说的事情，也就是你刚刚所说的那样，走上一条充满爱的道路，那么你就改变了世界。你做到了，Z世代。我知道。而且对我来说这很疯狂，我猜显然在前进的道路上有那么多不同的挑战和错误，以及正在发生在我们身上的真正的关键危机
every single day. But sometimes I do just look at people and think, have you, it's obviously been a while since it's crossed your mind that life is short. Like I see people. make decisions or get really caught up in small things. And I was like, it's, you obviously, like, haven't had a reminder as of recent that you don't get endless time here and that this is very sacred. And maybe that's also the benefit of having that spiritual core as being able to make better decisions, decisions and being able to let stress go, you know, and anxiety, let it flow through you. You're still experiencing it. Sometimes it's beyond your control, but being like, this is part of the kind of the cause that I was dealt, when am I going to make of this?
每天都在发生。但有时我看着人们，会想，你——显然已经很久没有意识到生命是短暂的了。比如我看到人们做出各种决定，或者深陷于鸡毛蒜皮的小事中。我想，很显然，你们最近没有得到提醒，意识到你们在这里的时间不是无限的，生命是非常神圣的。也许这也是拥有精神核心的好处，能够做出更好的决定，能够放下压力，你知道，还有焦虑，让它们穿透你。你仍然在经历这些。有时这超出了你的控制，但你会觉得，这是我拿到的剧本的一部分，我要用它来做些什么？
So what you just shared, I think is even more important for people in their 20s. Because, well, let me ask you. You know, it's my impression that people in their 20s in some ways are very gifted by birth generation, that there's more awareness, more openness in a good sense, sensitivity, perceptiveness. And that this notion that Gen Z was more tuned, more feeling is true. But because of that, it's even more important for Gen Z to build the spiritual core and walk a path, as you've described, as the path of love. Because you're going to feel things more. I think that you're right.
所以你刚才分享的内容，我认为对二十几岁的年轻人来说更为重要。因为，嗯，让我问你。你知道，我的印象是，二十几岁的年轻人在某种程度上由于出生的时代而天赋异禀，他们有更多的觉知、更好的开放性、敏感性、洞察力。Z世代更加敏锐、更有同理心，这种观念是真实的。但正因为如此，对于Z世代来说，建立精神核心并走上一条你所描述的“爱的道路”就更加重要。因为你们会更加深刻地感受到事物。我认为你是对的。
I think that this generation is also more in touch with what makes us different. There is less need for conformity. Whether that is being accepting of different, you know, sexual or gender identity or whatever color your skin is or your ethnicity or the power of your neurodivergence, whatever it is that makes you different, different, we're more accepting of it now. Like maybe that is also coming into it, do you think? So then we greet you with love. If I'm neurodivergent, if I looks the same or different than you, right, greet me with love.
我认为这一代人也更能切身感知到是什么让我们与众不同。对盲目顺从的需求减少了。无论是接纳不同的性取向、性别认同，还是你的肤色、种族，或是神经多样性的力量，无论是什么让你与众不同，我们现在都更能接纳它。也许这也融入其中了，你觉得呢？所以我们用爱来迎接你。如果我是神经多样性的，如果我的外表和你一样或不同，对吧，请用爱来迎接我。
So that's already your path of abundant love in action. I would say Gen Z is for all generations on Earth right now, you are the pathbreakers for what I would call relational spirituality, leading with love, welcoming everyone to the table. And where I think the opportunity might be is in what you just shared, which is in your own being to hold deep love. Because even though Gen Z's so loving to one another, you've just talked about a way where there's also a relationship to the higher power or the, you. universe that lifts and guides you, that you deserve as a soul on earth, love and connection, as well as being a source of giving that to others. No, absolutely. I've got two final questions for you that might go off the path a little bit.
所以这已经是你付诸行动的丰盛之爱的道路了。我想说，对于地球上现有的所有世代来说，Z世代就是我所谓的“关系灵性”的开拓者，以爱引领，欢迎所有人入席。我认为契机可能在于你刚才分享的内容，也就是在你自身的内在保持深沉的爱。因为尽管Z世代彼此关爱，但你刚才也谈到了一种与更高力量或宇宙的关系，这种力量会提升并指引你，作为地球上的灵魂，你值得拥有爱与连接，同时也成为将爱给予他人的源泉。不，绝对是的。我有最后两个问题想问你，可能会稍微偏离一点主题。
Good. I love that. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
很好。我喜欢这样。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一面成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush
这就是《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部两次吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什到底
to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
跟小金有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）大谈80年代的快克可卡因。把话说清楚，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时可以在某天聊聊快克，只是想让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们在追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程
Are you a good person? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow
你是个好人吗？因为你感到害怕。因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于疗愈、
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
成长、为人父母、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
暴露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这就引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I've got two final questions. you. So when I asked people, I was like, what do you want to know about spirituality and its intersection with mental health? And a lot of people said, how does having a spiritual core impact something like anxiety or depression, which we would typically say, or like the kind of general belief system right now is it's quite biological, it's quite genetic. Where does spirituality come into managing that lived experience? For most of the 20th century, you're completely right.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格（Greg）、莱斯利（Leslie）和迈克尔·马兰奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
People said, oh, well, mental health is biologically based, and spirituality is just some airy-fairy thing that has nothing to do with biology. But there's now a very rigorous, peer-reviewed science that shows that actually built into our biology is our seat of spiritual awareness. When we shared that beautiful council practice, there were very specific circuits that we've identified in the MRI that were running in your brain and my brain and in everyone's brain at the same time. The bonding network that lets us know we're loved and held. The parietal that puts in and out hard boundaries so we're distinct but we're also part of one family of life, when universe. A shift in our attention network so we can receive and perceive surprising new guidance.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trap》播客。我有最后两个问题。问你。所以当我问人们时，我说，你们想了解灵性及其与心理健康的交叉点吗？很多人说，拥有一个精神核心是如何影响焦虑或抑郁之类的事情的——我们通常会说，或者像现在的一种普遍信念系统那样，它在很大程度上是生物学的，在很大程度上是基因决定的。灵性在管理这种生活体验时体现在哪里？在20世纪的大部分时间里，你完全是对的。
So, you know, we actually are biologically built to have a spiritual life. That doesn't mean that spirituality is just, you know, a side effect of biology. It means that body, mind, and soul were one. And there's a neuro-docking station for spiritual awareness. So to back up knowing that, it's no longer, you know, it is now outdated to your point. And I'm so glad you put this front and center. It is outdated to say, oh, mental illness is biological. biological spirituality isn't. No, spirituality, like all of their human experiences, has biological underpinnings, a neuro seat in our brain. And when we strengthen our spiritual awareness, we are 80% less likely to become addicted. We are 60% more likely to recover from bumps in our lives without becoming downward, downward down, major depression. We are far more resilient.
人们说，哦，心理健康是基于生物学的，而灵性只是一些虚无缥缈的东西，与生物学毫无关系。但现在有了非常严谨、经过同行评议的科学表明，实际上，我们的精神觉知之座是内在于我们的生物学之中的。当我们分享那个美丽的理事会练习时，我们在核磁共振中发现了一些非常具体的回路，它们同时在你的大脑、我的大脑以及每个人的大脑中运转。这个联结网络让我们知道我们是被爱着和托举着的。顶叶设定了进出严密的边界，所以我们既是独立的，但也是生命同一家庭、同一宇宙的一部分。我们的注意力网络发生了转变，以便我们能够接收和感知令人惊讶的新指引。
We are far more able to connect with people. But it's not as simple a story as, oh, there's happy people who are spiritual and never get depressed, and then there's unhappy people who just aren't as spiritual. That's not the story. It's actually a deeper story, which is in our 20s, as I started sharing with you today when John broke up with me, there are times of unbelievable pain. But they are not necessarily medical depression. They're not necessarily psychopathology. Very often these are developmental depression. It's the knock at the door to ask bigger questions, the existential questions that you opened with. What is my purpose? What is the meaning in my life? What am I supposed to do with my life? Can I trust human beings?
所以，你知道，我们实际上在生物学上就是为了拥有精神生活而构建的。这并不意味着灵性只是生物学的副作用。这意味着身体、心灵和灵魂是一体的。这里有一个用于精神觉觉知的神经对接站。因此，了解了这一点后，它就不再是——按照你的观点，这现在已经过时了。我很高兴你把这一点放在了核心和显眼的位置。说“精神疾病是生物学的，灵性不是”，这种说法已经过时了。不，灵性像所有其他人类体验一样，有着生物学基础，在我们的大脑中有一个神经座位。当我们加强我们的精神觉知时，我们成瘾的可能性就会降低80%。我们从生活中的坎坷中恢复过来、而不会陷入严重抑郁的可能性要高出60%。我们的韧性要强得多。
And do I trust in love even if I'm not necessarily loved that? How do I want to be in this world? And that process, that is built into our children. genes is a process of existential search. When we hit our early 20s, our capacity for spirituality grows. We can love even more. We can probe even more deeply. We can see into the deep, sacred, transcendent nature of life in nature, in one another. We have these gifts that emerge in our 20s. But as this great gift of spiritual awareness boots up, it often can feel like a half, empty glass of spirituality while it's coming online. It can feel empty. It can feel confusing.
我们与人连接的能力要强得多。但这并不是一个简单的故事，好像“哦，有快乐的人，他们很有灵性，从不抑郁，然后有不快乐的人，他们不够灵性”。事情不是这样的。这其实是一个更深层的故事，也就是在我们二十几岁的时候，正如我今天开始对你分享的，当约翰和我分手时，有时会有难以置信的痛苦。但它们不一定是医学上的抑郁。它们不一定是精神病理学。通常这些是发展性抑郁。这是敲门声，促使我们去思考更大的问题，也就是你开篇时提出的存在主义问题。我的目标是什么？我生命的意义是什么？我该如何度过我的一生？我能信任人类吗？
It can feel like, how do I put my finger on this? And many people in their 20s say, you know, when I don't let myself think about these questions, I get even more depressed. I have no choice. I've got to take this on. And so I'm not against medication, but medication alone is insufficient to address the most important work of your entire life, which is building your spiritual core in your 20s. Based on science, and it's 25 years of very good, you know, top American Journal of Psychiatry, the American Medical Association, top peer review science. Depression is a gateway to spiritual awakening in our early 20s. It is, often in our mid-20s. Depression is a knock at the door, an existential struggle to awaken our deeper knowing, our seat of spiritual awareness.
即使我不一定能得到那种爱，我也能信任爱吗？我想以怎样的方式存在于这个世界？而这个过程，是内置于我们的基因中的，是一个存在主义探索的过程。当我们进入二十出头时，我们对灵性的容量会增长。我们可以爱得更多。我们可以探索得更深。我们可以洞察自然界中、人与人之间生命的深刻、神圣和超验的本质。我们在二十多岁时会涌现出这些天赋。但是，随着精神觉醒的这一伟大天赋启动，当它正在上线时，它通常会让人感觉灵性就像一个半空的杯子。它会感觉空虚。它会让人感到困惑。
And once we build that, the next time something goes wrong, we have built and ready a spiritual response to disappointment, a spiritual response to not knowing where I'm going. And that literally shows up in the brain as neuroprotective against a recurrence of major depression. That's incredible. I love that there is this combination of biology and then of, you know, neuroimaging. And then also of this like profoundly intangible thing. You know, you cannot reach, you know, you reach out and touch your spirituality. Also we think, but you're literally saying, no, if you want to look inside your brain, if you wanted to poke around, you would find these paths, you would find these neurons, these synapses that are directly responsible for you,
它会让人觉得，我该如何准确把握这一点？许多二十几岁的年轻人说，你知道，当我让自己不去想这些问题时，我会变得更加抑郁。我别无选择。我必须承担起这个责任。所以我并不反对药物治疗，但单靠药物治疗是不足以应对你一生中最重要的事情的——也就是在二十多岁时建立你的精神核心。基于科学，这是25年来非常好的、你知道的，发表在顶尖的《美国精神病学杂志》、美国医学会、顶尖同行评审科学上的研究。在我们的二十出头，抑郁是通往精神觉醒的大门。确实如此，通常在我们的二十岁中期。抑郁是一声敲门声，是一场唤醒我们更深知觉、唤醒我们的精神觉知之座的存在主义挣扎。
you know, having a sense of being and a sense of place. Like you said, the neurosate, which is just so cool. And you know what's interesting as well is how outdated. I'm thinking about like when I did my degree and when I did like all my training, how outdated the current like the current system and education system is. Because only like maybe seven years ago, I remember sitting in a class and being like depression is biological and that is purely it and there is nothing more to it. It's inherited. Blah, blah, blah. And there was nothing about like experiences.
一旦我们建立起这一点，下一次有什么事情出错时，我们就已经建立并准备好了一种对失望的精神回应，一种对不知道自己将去往何方的精神回应。这在字面上表现为大脑中对重度抑郁症复发的神经保护作用。这太不可思议了。我喜欢这种生物学与神经成像的结合。还有这种深刻无形的事物。你知道，你无法伸手去触摸你的灵性。至少我们是这么认为的，但你字面上的意思是，不，如果你想看看你的大脑内部，如果你想去探究，你会发现这些路径，你会发现这些神经元、这些突触，它们直接负责让你
There was nothing about deep questions. There was nothing about, you know, how strengthening everything else in your life and not just social connections, not just physical health, but actually thinking deeply and having a philosophy that might bind bad experience together might have. help. So it's really incredible that you're putting it out there for this next generation of, you know, a lot of psychology students listen to this show. A lot of people who go on to be counselors and therapists are going to have a different perspective. So I'm going to ask you one final question. If you had to give three rapid fire practices that someone could do
拥有存在感和归属感。就像你说的神经座位，这真是太酷了。你知道更有趣的是，当前的体系和教育体系是多么过时。我想起自我获得学位以及接受所有培训的时候，当前的体系和教育体系是多么过时。因为仅仅在七年前左右，我还记得坐在课堂上，听到“抑郁是生物学的，纯粹就是这样，别无其他。它是遗传的。等等等等”。而其中完全没有关于经历的内容。
daily to get to that point of having an awakened brain or building their spiritual core, what would you recommend? In my book, The Awakened Brain, I list three practices that we use on the Columbia University campus. They're now used on about 30 campuses in the United States. One of them is hosting counsel, which we just shared, because that is your direct connection to transcendent relationship, right? Your higher power, your higher self, and those who truly have your best interest in mind.
没有任何关于深度问题的内容。没有任何关于加强生活中其他一切的内容——不仅仅是社会联系，不仅仅是身体健康，而是进行深刻思考以及拥有一套能够将糟糕经历凝聚在一起的哲学可能会有所帮助的内容。所以，你把它展示给下一代人，这真的很不可思议。你知道，很多心理学专业的学生都在收听这个节目。许多以后将成为咨询师和治疗师的人将拥有不同的视角。所以我将问你最后一个问题。如果你必须给出三种可以让人每天进行的快速练习，从而达到拥有觉醒的大脑或建立精神核心的境界，你会推荐什么？在我的书《觉醒的大脑》（The Awakened Brain）中，我列出了我们在哥伦比亚大学校园里使用的三种练习。它们现在已被美国大约30个校园所采用。其中之一就是主持理事会（hosting counsel），也就是我们刚才分享的，因为那是你与超验关系的直接连接，对吧？你的更高力量、更高的自我，以及那些真正为了你的最佳利益着想的人。
The other two practices are called the Road of Life, which cultivates what you shared, which is a stance, an operating manual of how to engage in a dialogue with the universe. And then the third practice has to do with finding someone with whom you can share your spiritual path, because it's wonderful if you can go through, whether you call it the sangha or the fellowship or the journey group. But remember your practice, your people, you're passing your purpose. Your people are important and you're creating people here. So in the awakened brain, I share these practices. And I also share in the awakened brain the references to all of these scientific articles. So you can go online, pull up the article and say, you know, listen, I'd like to share today in my counseling class or with my therapist. There's a scientific article that says, you know, spirituality is really important.
另外两项练习被称为“生命之路”（the Road of Life），它培养了你所分享的那种立场，也就是一套如何与宇宙进行对话的操作指南。第三项练习则与寻找一个你可以与他/她分享你的精神道路的人有关，因为如果你能经历这一切——无论你称之为僧伽（sangha）、同道还是同行小组——那都是美妙的。但请记住你的练习，你的人，你的过往，你的目标。你的人很重要，你正在这里创造社群。所以在《觉醒的大脑》中，我分享了这些练习。我还在《觉醒的大脑》中分享了所有这些科学文章的参考文献。所以你可以在网上查阅这篇文章，然后说，“听着，我想在今天的咨询课上或与我的治疗师分享。有一篇科学文章说，灵性在引导我度过绝望和抑郁方面真的很重要，当我从抑郁中恢复时，如果我将心力、注意力和焦点放在那里，我就是在建立我的精神核心。”所以它的目的是赋能于你与生俱来的权利，赋能于你本来面目的那个真实的你。没有人是不具灵性的。你是有灵性的。问题不在于是否具备，而在于你如何在自己的旅程中亲自去实现你这伟大的天赋。为这一集的结束画上了一个多么美丽的句号。我想说这本书，《觉醒的大脑》。现在已经出版了吗？《觉醒的大脑》及其故事、科学和练习现在已经出版了。
in making my way through despair and depression, that when I'm recovering from depression, I'm building the spiritual core if I put my heart and mind and focus there. So it's intended to be empowering of your own birthright of who you already are. There's no one who isn't spiritual. You are spiritual. It's not if it's how in your own journey you personally want to realize your great gift. What a beautiful way to finish the episode. And I want to say this book, the awakened brain. Is it out right now? The awakened brain is out in its stories and its science and its practices.
这正是我们在本节目中讨论的内容。没有科学和深度的思考，你就无法获得疗愈和心灵的清明。所以我真的强烈推荐大家去买这本书。我会在本节目的简介中留下购买链接，以及在哪里可以找到你、你的Instagram、你的Facebook、你的网站，因为我认为我们需要更多这样的对话。所以谢谢你，丽莎博士（Dr. Lisa），来到我们的节目。你真是这一生中精神旅程的卓越发声者。谢谢你。哦，天哪。多么美好的赞美。
And that is exactly what we talk about on this show. Like you can't have healing and mental clarity without the science and without the deep thoughts. So I really would recommend going out and getting this book. I'll leave a link to it in the description of the episode along with where we can find you and your Instagram, your Facebook, your website, because I think that we need more of these conversations. So thank you, Dr. Lisa, for coming on the show. Well, you are a magnificent voice for spiritual journey in this life. Thank you. Oh, my gosh. What a beautiful compliment.
我真的很感激。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时关注并在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你对这次讨论有进一步的想法，请在Instagram上私信我：That Psychology Podcast。我想和你聊聊。我想谈谈你的想法，因为这对我来说极其感人，如果你也深有同感，请让我知道。我们也在那里接受节目建议。所以如果你想要后续的节目，如果你想要更多这样的内容，我也非常渴望听到你的反馈。直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对自己温柔一些，我们很快就会再聊。
I really appreciate that. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to follow along and leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. have further thoughts about this discussion, DM me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. I want to have a chat to you about it. I want to talk about what you think because it was incredibly moving for me and if you found that to be the same for you, please let me know. And we also take episode suggestions over there. So if you want a follow-up episode, if you want more content like this, I also would love your feedback. Until next time, stay safe, be kind and be gentle to yourself and we will talk very soon.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一面成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是很大的一刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代那样。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一位深谙此道的有执照的专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，欧文斯女士，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trap》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有两名经历过同样事情的男子：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我大受震撼。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对应有的惩罚。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。